prophet muhammed peace be upon him was
illiterate unlettered couldn't read or
write how could he then write a book
that was so eloquent that none of the
poets of arabia could answer that none
of them could bring anything like it and
they tried the quran talks about the sun
and the moon and the planetary bodies
being in an orbit
you know till very recently scientists
were were saying that the sun doesn't
have an orbit i mean the sun and
very recently they said you know it does
it's a very slow orbit but it does have
an orbit how could a man in a desert who
didn't know astronomy who didn't have
access to the works of the greeks and
the romans and all of this
even the greeks and romans didn't know
this thing how could he have known that
[Music]
[Applause]
lord
[Music]
brothers and sisters i am so excited we
have an event coming up we got sheikh
uthman ibn farooq we got dr kareem abu
zaid and other speakers we're going to
do a live show where in orland park
here with this wonderful community
make sure you're there you can see the
beautiful dome over here it's coming up
this sunday
august 28th i want to see all of you
there come out and support we're having
a benefit dinner i'll see you in orland
park inshallah
we're getting ready for the event
sunday this sunday the 28th
here's the event
and i got the man himself who's going to
be
responsible for the food
introduce yourself
all right so make sure you guys are
there
we're going to have some wonderful food
what kind of food are we going to have
shay the best kebabs
yes
yeah
what they say but what they don't know
everybody knows what he has
[Music]
we've been told that they're out to kill
us all salaam alaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
americans about islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about islam
no do you know anything about islam
no sadly do you know anything about
islam uh not really do you know anything
about islam
no i'm sorry you know what islam means
islam uh
no we've been told that they're out to
kill us all that's what you've been told
that muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what i say on tv
anything
i know it's in the middle east isn't it
well that you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many americans who don't
know about islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean's
center the first megadawa center in
america we have five hundred thousand
dollars left and we need your help to
finish click to donate right now may god
almighty allah reward all of you